An alien with a horse head.
The "Frog of Thunder."
A couple of mutants.
Heroes from the future and other universes,
even the DC universe.
When it comes to Marvel Comics, Thor Odinson
isn't the only one who's been worthy of wielding
the hammer.
First appearing in 1962's Journey Into Mystery
#83, Thor Odinson is initially the alter ego
of Dr. Donald Blake, who finds Mjolnir and
proves worthy to wield it.
Thor and Blake can switch places by smacking
Mjolnir on the ground.
It's later revealed that Blake is a construct
of Thor's father Odin, and while there are
a few other attempts to saddle Thor with a
secret identity, for the most part, he exists
solely as Thor.
Even during periods when Thor Odinson briefly
loses his powers, he never stays on the sidelines
for very long.
Even without Mjolnir, he refuses to be anything
but a hero.
"At least make it a challenge for me!"
When the Ultimate Thor is introduced in 2002's
Ultimates #4, no one's sure if he really is
Thor.
Nick Fury tries to recruit him into the Ultimates
while he's a far-left activist in Norway who
has published self-help books and is popular
on lecture circuits.
He was also institutionalized for over a year
after his revelation that he was the Son of
Odin.
It isn't until the second Ultimates volume
that his godhood is confirmed.
The Ultimate Thor is one of the many heroes
lost when Marvel's Ultimate line officially
closed with 2015's Ultimate End.
His unique version of Mjolnir remains, though,
as this half-hammer, half-ax appears in Asgard
at the end of 2015's Thors miniseries and
has since had a significant impact on the
course of events in the prime Marvel Universe.
As a result of the 2014 line-wide event "Original
Sin," Thor Odinson loses his worthiness.
In that year's Thor #1, a female Thor takes
up the hammer and fills the void that Odinson
leaves behind.
Her identity was left a mystery for a time,
but eventually Thor's former main squeeze
Jane Foster is revealed to be the new hammer-wielder
in Thor #8.
"Jane?!"
Jane then remains Thor for four years.
In 2018's Mighty Thor #705, she's forced to
sacrifice Mjolnir in order to defeat the monster
Mangog, thereby losing the power of Thor.
More recently, in the conclusion to 2019's
"War of the Realms" event, Jane replaces Valkyrie
in the ongoing series Valkyrie: Jane Foster.
Walt Simonson's run on Thor remains one of
the most well-remembered stints in Marvel
Comics history.
That includes his introduction of horse-faced
hero Beta Ray Bill, who proves himself worthy
of the power of Thor.
In 1983's Thor #337, Thor intercepts a spaceship
at Nick Fury's request, but its pilot turns
violent.
During their clash, Bill lifts Mjolnir, only
seeking to use it against Thor.
They eventually work things out, and Odin
decrees that since Bill has proven himself
worthy, he and Thor must fight for Mjolnir's
possession.
Bill wins the fight, but refuses to take the
hammer.
So instead, Odin has the dwarves of Nidavellir
create a new hammer named Stormbreaker for
Bill.
In 1978's Thor #276, cameraman Roger "Red"
Norvell captures Thor Odinson's belt of strength
and iron gloves, allowing him to become a
new Thor capable of wielding Mjolnir.
The new red-haired Thor seems more villain
than hero at first, but he eventually proves
himself worthy of the title when he sacrifices
himself to save Asgard two issues later.
And that isn't the end of Red Norvell.
He earns a spot in Valhalla for his sacrifice,
and Odin resurrects him in Thor #478 to replace
Thor, whom Odin feels is neglecting his duties
to Asgard.
Since then, Red has essentially been in limbo,
as he was last seen in 1997's Journey Into
Mystery #513.
In "The Asgardian Wars," stretched across
1985's New Mutants Special Edition #1 and
X-Men Annual #9, Loki tempts Storm from the
X-Men by giving her what seems to be the power
of Thor.
When her friends arrive on Asgard to save
her, Loki's magic makes them all appear as
enemies.
Loki crafts a powerful hammer for Ororo, and
she nearly kills Wolverine with its magic
and gives Hela a run for her money.
Eventually, Ororo sees through Loki's magic
and relinquishes her power, knowing that keeping
it would mean being Loki's puppet.
Despite this sacrifice, "The Asgardian Wars"
isn't the last appearance of this particular
goddess of thunder, as she's shown to still
have access to this power in 2018's X-Men:
Gold #26.
"Do you know what happens to a toad when it's
struck by lightning?"
"The same thing that happens to everyone else."
If you've ever wondered what Thor would look
like in a dystopian future, then you'd better
check out 1987's Thor #384, in which Dargo
Ktor is transformed into a much spikier version
of our hero.
In the 26th century, a massive corporation
called Corp rules over the Earth.
Dargo is a member of the secretive Cult of
the Hammer that somehow manages to locate
Mjolnir, though he doesn't believe in stories
of thunder gods.
When Loki uses the forces of Corp to assault
the Cult, Dargo grasps Mjolnir's handle and
proves himself worthy.
Dargo also appears again a few more times,
including as a member of the original Thor
Corps.
At the very end of 1986's Thor #363, a disguised
Loki turns his half-brother into a frog.
Thor remains froggy for a few issues, thereby
becoming Throg, Frog of Thunder.
Then in 2009, a new Throg emerged.
In Lockjaw & the Pet Avengers #1, we meet
Simon Walterson, who's cursed by a witch and
becomes Throg full time.
He's become kind of popular since then.
You can croak fear into the hearts of your
enemies as Throg in LEGO Marvel Super-Heroes
2, and he also had his own story in 2017's
Mighty Thor #700.
More recently, Throg kicked interstellar butt
as the tiniest member of the Asgardians of
the Galaxy, and he also showed up very briefly
on the Loki TV show.
"Ugh!
Ahh!"
For a time, Thor maintained the secret identity
Sigurd Janson, whose closest circle of friends
included Eric Masterson.
In 1989's Thor #408, Thor begs his father
to save Masterson's life after he's fatally
wounded by the villain Mongoose.
Odin solves the problem by using his magic
to merge Thor and Eric together.
When they're eventually separated, Odin creates
the mace Thunderstrike for Eric, granting
him abilities comparable to Thor's.
Eric names himself Thunderstrike after the
mace.
Unfortunately, he ultimately makes the mistake
of using a weapon called the Bloodaxe, as
it possesses him with its power.
In 1995's Thunderstrike #24, he regains control
of himself long enough to make the ultimate
sacrifice in order to defeat the Bloodaxe.
A decade before Jane Foster proved herself
worthy, there was Thor Girl.
Her real name is Tarene, an alien gifted with
cosmic powers whose coming was foretold billions
of years ago by an alien sorcerer.
She uses her abilities to turn herself into
an Asgardian goddess in 2001's Thor #33.
For a time, she acts as Thor Odinson's ally,
but she eventually loses most of her power
in battle with the demon Surtur.
Tarene then remains on the periphery of the
Marvel Universe.
She becomes a part of the government's Initiative
project during "Civil War" and even battles
the Hulk and his Warbound in the 2007 event
"World War Hulk."
She's last seen in a later event, "Fear Itself,"
during which she grows tired of humanity and
leaves Earth for spaceways.
After the events of 2015's "Secret Wars,"
the Ultimate Thor's version of Mjolnir appears
in Old Asgard.
Thor Odinson initially seems to want to retrieve
the weapon for himself in the miniseries "Unworthy
Thor," but he eventually decides it isn't
for him.
We learn in Mighty Thor #20 that Volstagg,
the large, red-haired member of the Warriors
Three, takes up the hammer instead.
He then becomes the War Thor shortly after
he's traumatized when he fails to save a group
of children from a fire demon.
When Volstagg tries and fails to stop the
monster Mangog in 2017's Mighty Thor #701,
the beast crushes the Ultimate version of
Mjolnir and leaves Volstagg bleeding and helpless.
“If you even think about betraying him…”
“You’ll…kill me?
Evidently, there will be a line.”
The third issue of Civil War ends with a bit
of a shocker.
Thor had been missing and presumed dead, but
he appears on the last page ready to do some
damage.
In the following issue, he kills Bill Foster,
a.k.a.
Goliath.
We later learn that this is not Thor but a
cyborg clone, and the mythic warrior Hercules
crushes the clone's head with his own hammer
in Civil War #7.
The clone later awakens in 2009's Avengers:
The Initiative #21 and renames himself Ragnarok.
He spends some years as a villain, recruited
into the villainous Green Goblin's team of
Dark Avengers, and then he eventually joins
the Thunderbolts.
He was last seen in 2013's Dark Avengers #190
on a mission on an alternate Earth.
After the death of Eric Masterson, his mace
is left in the hands of the Avengers.
In 2010's Thunderstrike #1, Captain America
gives the mace to Eric's son Kevin.
After using the weapon to try to pry some
civilians loose when they're pinned under
a car, Kevin experiences the same transformation
as his late father.
After a short solo series, Kevin joins the
young "Avengers Academy" heroes, fighting
alongside them in the 2011 line-wide event
"Fear Itself."
He then later joins the ranks of the Asgardians
of the Galaxy.
Often appearing more like Odin than Thor,
King Thor has one eye, one arm, and little
patience for his younger counterparts.
He joins the Thor of the present and the Thor
of the past to help defeat Gorr the God Butcher,
and later reunites with them in the 2019 event
"War of the Realms."
King Thor remains a constant throughout Jason
Aaron's tenure on Thor, and we eventually
see the Thor of the present suffer the wounds
that are old news to King Thor.
In June 2019, Marvel announced that Aaron
would conclude his time writing Thor with
the four-part miniseries "King Thor," focusing
primarily on this future Odinson.
"So I like a lot of different Thors.
I don't think we have to pick just one."
Thor wasn't always worthy of Mjolnir.
Impatient for his chance with the hammer,
the young Thor is often seen testing his ability
to lift the hammer, only to curse at it when
he fails.
Without Mjolnir, the youthful Thor carries
the powerful ax Jarnbjorn.
Unfortunately, it can't grant Thor the gift
of flight like Mjolnir, so instead he rides
a chariot pulled by his two flying goats.
This younger, ax-wielding Odinson aids the
present-day Thor both in his battle against
the God Butcher and his final conflict with
Malekith in "War of the Realms."
In the 2018 Marvel event "Infinity Wars,"
a separate universe is created in the Soul
Stone whose inhabitants are the combination
of pre-existing Marvel characters.
In particular, the stories of Iron Man and
Thor merge to become that of Stark Odinson,
the Iron Hammer.
Almost all of the villains, friends, and lovers
of both Thor and Iron Man are combined to
create the cast of Iron Hammer's stories.
Madame Masque and Hela, for example, are combined
to make Madame Hel, while the dark elf Kurse
and Crimson Dynamo come together as the Krimson
Kurse.
Iron Hammer was last seen in 2019's "Secret
Warps" event.
As you can probably tell, it's not unusual
for a handful of different people to simultaneously
call themselves "Thor" or at least to claim
some of his power.
But in 1993 that was still relatively novel,
and that was when Marvel launched the miniseries
Thor Corps.
The storyline united Thor Odinson, Beta Ray
Bill, the original Thunderstrike, and Dargo
the 26th century Thor all on one team.
The four embark on an adventure that sees
them saving reality itself and battling villains
and heroes from all over the multiverse.
It would be over two decades before the phrase
"Thor Corps" became regularly heard in the
comics vernacular again, and this time it
was a very different group of Thors with a
much larger roster.
In the 2015 event "Secret Wars," Doctor Doom
creates a patchwork planet called Battleworld
with alternate reality versions of different
characters sharing the same planet.
For his police force, "God" Doom creates a
new version of the Thor Corps, which includes
hundreds of Thors from across the multiverse.
There are familiar characters like Ultimate
Thor and Beta Ray Bill, alongside tons of
new versions like a Gamora Thor, a Lizard
Thor, and even a Groot Thor who says only
"I am Thor."
"You speak Groot?"
"Yes, they taught it on Asgard as an elective."
The Thors take center stage in the miniseries
Thors, during which the Ultimate Thor investigates
a string of serial murders of different Jane
Fosters across Battleworld.
The series ends with the Thor Corps joining
the battle against God Doom, the death of
the Ultimate Thor, and the Ultimate Mjolnir
appearing in Old Asgard.
On Earth-928 in the year 2099, Thor is worshiped
once more.
Along with his fellow Asgardians, Thor left
years earlier in response to the corporation
Alchemax stoking anti-hero rage.
Those who couldn't escape to different worlds
either ended up dead or quit being a hero.
The Church of Thor and its followers, known
as Thorites, wait anxiously for the return
of the God of Thunder.
But unbeknownst to the Thorites, Thor and
nearly all other Asgardians have already been
killed.
Only Loki survived by running and hiding.
In Punisher 2099 #13, Alchemax engineers its
own Asgardians to act as the true gods returned
to Earth.
Cecil McAdam, a janitor at the Church, willingly
allows the corporation to turn him into their
version of the Thunder God.
He's genuinely motivated by a desire to be
heroic, but his corporate masters use him
to distract from their dark dealings.
When separated from his hammer, McAdam chooses
to chase it into an explosion, seemingly dying,
rather than return to an ordinary life.
The Marvel 2099 universe wasn't quite done
with Thor after Reverend McAdam's demise.
In an echo of his Silver Age return, Captain
America was once again discovered in a block
of ice after years of being assumed killed
in the superhero purge.
Around the same time, Alchemax located the
true hammer of Thor, Mjolnir.
Steve Rogers proves worthy and is able to
hoist the hammer, thereby becoming a heroic
Thor for the era.
Together with Spider-Man and a league of other
heroes in 2099: Manifest Destiny #1, they
begin to repair the fallen world of 2099.
This one-shot story marks the original end
of the 2099 line, as it sends the universe
off on an upbeat note.
Marvel has typically depicted the Asgardian
apocalypse of Ragnarok as a localized event.
Readers have watched the event destroy Asgard
and the gods several times, all without doing
much damage to Midgard, aka Earth.
But in What If?
Age of Ultron #3, Earth is not spared.
After slaying Thor and destroying Asgard,
the monstrous serpent Jormungand then targets
and kills scores of Avengers.
Soon only a handful of heroes still live,
as they decide to take on Jormungand despite
the incredibly long odds.
Amazingly, their boldness pays off.
By taking the fight to Jormungand, the team
ends up in a position to find Mjolnir amongst
the rubble, and Black Widow then grabs Thor's
abandoned hammer.
She's evidently been made worthy by her time
fighting to forestall the end of humanity,
and thus she can hoist the hammer skyward
and become the new God of Thunder.
While the book only briefly shows her efforts,
Nick Fury's narration confirms that she indeed
carried the day, and rather spectacularly
at that.
"I want you to meet Agent Romanoff."
X-Men's Rogue has been a fan favorite for
so long that newer readers might not know
that she used to run with villains like the
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants.
During that time, she even took on Carol Danvers
and permanently absorbed her abilities, like
flight and super strength.
What If...?
#66, entitled "What If...
Rogue Possessed the Powers of Thor," took
readers back to this era.
After breaking out of prison with her fellow
Brotherhood members, Rogue and the other mutants
find the Avengers ready to put them back in
their cells.
Rogue absorbs the powers of Thor, who falls
into a coma and dies soon after.
Now permanently possessing the powers of a
god, Rogue briefly falls into cahoots with
Loki.
Persuading her to help him kill Odin, the
God of Mischief mounts a rebellion.
He sends Rogue and his troops to invade Asgard,
and things look pretty desperate until Thor
approaches Rogue on the astral plane.
He convinces her that she can still be a hero
regardless of her past.
So she accepts her new role as Goddess of
Thunder, routs Loki's forces, and gains acceptance
from the gods and the Avengers.
In the Disney+ animated series What If...?,
the episode "What If...
Thor Were An Only Child?"
sees the God of Thunder as an immortal partier
who can also nonetheless still wield his hammer.
Without Loki to make his life miserable or
inspire him to protect others, he's lived
a charmed life devoid of consequence or responsibility.
As such, he's a charming but reckless moron
who hops from planet to planet throwing parties
that are so intense that they end up ravaging
multiple worlds.
After Thor arrives on Earth, things finally
start to change when Jane Foster helps him
see the value of humanity and Captain Marvel
keeps his destructive impulses focused on
her.
In the end, the heroes of Earth manage to
save the planet in a manner both silly and
logical.
As it turns out, the best way to stop a man-child
in his tracks is by calling his mother.
"Oh, hello, Mother, good to see you.
Welcome to our study group."
Wonder Woman
Yes, even DC characters can be worthy of Mjolnir.
During the blockbuster DC versus Marvel event,
cosmic forces pitted heroes from both universes
against each other.
After Thor loses his hammer while battling
DC's Captain Marvel, Wonder Woman then comes
across Mjolnir.
She's able to lift it and quickly absorb the
powers of the God of Thunder, emerging from
the lightning in a new costume, ready for
a fight.
But when her chosen opponent Storm arrives,
she quickly discards the hammer in the name
of a fair and honorable fight and promptly
gets wrecked by the mutant.
Considering that she's fighting for the very
existence of the DC universe, it might seem
odd that Wonder Woman would so quickly cede
an advantage.
However, it's worth noting that the results
of the crossover were based on fan voting.
So perhaps the creators felt it was far too
unrealistic to give Storm her fan-affirmed
victory over Wonder Woman when the Justice
Leaguer had both her own power and Thor's.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.